where can you go to find all the best
horror movies you've never heard of one
word Netflix the streaming service is
packed with zombies and vampires and
hauntings that have flown under the
radar for too long
here are the most underrated scream
worthy streamable films currently
available on Netflix Midnight Meat Train
before he gave his voice to a bionic Lee
enhanced space racoon Bradley Cooper was
the star of this incredibly creepy
bizarrely overlooked New York horror
story midnight me train tells the story
of Leon a photographer who accidentally
uncovers the existence of a murderous
butcher who's using the New York City
subway as his own personal
slaughterhouse needless to say things
get gory and the film goes for broke in
its final scene with a seriously twisted
surprise ending sadly a delayed and
limited theatrical release kept Midnight
Meat Train from getting the attention it
deserved especially considering Cooper
star power and the movies production
values but that just makes it one of
Netflix's most hidden gems train to
Busan the only thing scarier than a
roving pack of zombies is being trapped
with them in a claustrophobic train
that's flying through the Korean
countryside at 100 miles an hour
enter train to Busan a fabulous
under-the-radar horror film that milks
its unique setting for all it's worth
the titular train is barreling through a
world overrun by the undead Alan for a
southern resort city that's rumored to
be the last safe stronghold for Humanity
trained in Busan was a hidden seek and
Film Festival in 2016 and broke box
office records in Korea but it was
almost completely overlooked by American
audiences and critics fortunately it's
right for discovery as a new addition to
Netflix in Sapporo library the pact
despite a promising release at Sundance
in 2012 the pact never found the
audience deserved during its original
limited theatrical run but this smart
spooky horror flick is the perfect pick
for streaming starting caity lotz who
you might know is there was original
ass-kicking canary the back tells the
story of a young woman with a troubled
past whose mother has died and his
sister has gone missing and whose house
may or may not have a few hundred
skeletons hanging around in its closet
director Nicholas McCarthy rings every
last iota of suspense from his minuscule
budget and lobsters performance anchors
but is ultimately a quiet but intensely
creepy film we are still here
the debut film from director Ted Kagan
is a modern-day throwback to classic
horror it tells the story of a couple
mourning the death of their sons who
moved to the country in search of a
fresh start only to find themselves
haunted by an unspeakable evil
you're still here premiered at South by
Southwest and 2015 was considered by
many critics to be one of the best
horror films of the year with an
inventive plot and just the right amount
of artfully executed gore since then
though it's been tragically overlooked
VHS to the original horror anthology
film VHS has gotten a decent amount of
attention for its inventive bite-sized
tales of Terror because why take two
hours for a sloper and Fright Fest when
you can pack multiple horror stories
into the same amount of time VHS was
successful enough to spawn a sequel
which sticks to the original format but
offers up an entirely fresh crop of
scares like its predecessor VHS to
include something for everyone from
zombies to aliens
- haunted body parts stake lands this
underrated apocalypse film tells the
story of an orphaned teenage boy named
Martin living in a world where vampires
have overrun every human stronghold with
the help of a mysterious vampire hunter
known only as mr. Martin makes his way
across America in search of a safe haven
dodging killers both human and
supernatural making the most of a tiny
budget steak land is the best of both
worlds mash-up between the apocalyptic
horrors of The Walking Dead and the
action of blade a smart and compelling
survival drama full of interesting
characters thoughtful social commentary
and of course blood sucking monsters
thanks for watching
put the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love too
[Music]